dass ich mir egoisten knurrt das
meeresleben fertig aber und vor sie
verlassen und klug dass man mir am
aussterben oder hinfällig werden
irgendwie dass das nicht der moment wo
sie sich dann am ostrand ich finde sich
das thema man muss vor allem zum thema
machen solange man es eben nur zum thema
kommen machen und alle interpreten
irgendwann wenn es denn so wie die
schule lockmittel sind gestorben und
zwei monate was man hat ja ich hoffe nur
pakt für sie die polizei gut 20 jahre
sie hatte kurz selbstwertgefühl sie weiß
weil sie weiß ich und was sie was sie
für ihn war okay und wir haben ausser
die telefonnummer
ja aus gesund sagte gross
ja
ich finde das nehmen wir so viel betrieb
ist uns für ihr ist dass sie sich sich
entwickeln so viel macht und vielleicht
nicht machen wir machen das projekt die
untersuchung dauert
[Musik]
das finanzielle das und institutionen
professionelle bestand